so hier haben uns gemülich gem eine
Stunde rund brauchen wir wir fangen mit
einer Standardfrage an wie ist die Lage
die Lage ist
entspannt aber nicht
hoffnungslos wieso nicht hoffnungslos na
ich bin gerade jetzt auf Promotion reise
für mein neues Album matchpoint und das
ist jetzt hier die dritte Woche glaube
ich und das ist halt ein ganzen Tag wie
es nicht kennen ganzen Tag Interview mhm
ähm dieselben
ähm schlechten Fragen immer wieder super
neue Antworten m
ich habe festgestellt weil eigentlich
macht ein gutes Interview die guten
Antworten aus und nicht die schlechten
Fragen ich glaube auch ja und na ja und
dann ist man dann so am Ende der Woche
also wenn es dann ich glaube morgen ist
es dann erstmal ist erst etwas Pause ne
mhm äh und dann merkt man dann
eigentlich schon wenn man entspannt Sim
nach einem Film dann merkt man
eigentlich was man getan hat ne solange
man noch dabei ist und in der Spannung
ist dann zieht man das alles durch und
dann merkt man das schon oh ist es denn
so bei den vielen schlechten
Fragen dass man dann manchmal doch am
Ende des Tages etwas ich sag mal
ausgeleiert ist nee also wenn es mir gar
nicht behagt dann sage ich schon also
sie können sich vorstellen die Frage hö
ich jetzt zum ersten Mal also nächste
bitte aber meistens bin ich da ganz
gnäig und und beantwortet dir auch und
so weil für den Fragesteller ist es ja
immer zum ersten Mal ja ja also was sind
bei ihnen die Standardfragen wo sie
lieber nicht mehr drauf antworten dann
haben wir die nämlich schon mal abgehen
muss ich dir jetzt stellen okay
ähm was sind sie denn mehr Musiker oder
ähäh Schauspieler äh wie es meinen
Kindern geht ja ob wir zu Hause ob die
für mich Konkurrenz sind und so äh ganz
Schlaue Fragen und
ähm ja das sind so die die Top Drei mhm
auf der auf der shitlist sozusagen auf
der shitliste das sind die auch wo sie
dann sagen ach lieber nicht oder es gibt
ja Sendung wenn es live ist da kann man
ja dem nicht ausweichen doch da kann man
auch sagen ach lieber nicht wieso ja
wissen Sie die Frage da fällt mir keine
kreative Antwort mehr ein keine neue ja
ich glaube nicht dass die Leute das
wirklich so interessiert ja kann man
doch auch ganz nett machen was möchten
Sie denn am liebsten gefragt
werden eigentlich gar nichts abermer
doch wieder am Punkt am anf nee nee äh
ach na ja man ich denke wenn ich ein
Interview mit mir selbst machen würde
ähm dann würde ich mir mal überlegen was
ist der vielleicht noch nicht gefragt
worden oder sowas ne und dann gibt's
immer noch irgendwelche Fragen die noch
nie gestellt wden z.B wie ich mit so
einem riesenalent umgehe selbst ne ja
mit so einem genialen Talent oder wie
wie wie ich es geschafft habe so normal
zu bleiben z.B ne ja wie wie gehen sie
mit so einem riesen Talent um jetzt habe
ich mir gedacht dass das jetzt so
funktioniert
ganz gut ganz gut man muss ja irgendwie
man ist ja eigentlich ein normaler
Mensch ja jetzt kommt dieses Talent dazu
wo man natürlich leicht verführt ist und
das sieht man auch an vielen anderen zu
glauben man wäre was Besonderes mit so
einem Talent oder man hat mehr Vorrechte
als anderen oder man möchte anders
behandelt werden und
so und sich da selbst auch mit Hilfe
anderer Freunde Familie
die das beobachten dann wieder runter zu
beamen und zu sagen nee das muss man
jetzt einfach so auch als was ganz
normales hinnehmen für einen
selbst ja da wenn man sich da mal
ernsthaft damit auseinandersetzt ähm ist
das gar nicht so einfach manchmal wie
ist in ihre in ihrer Familie ihre Söhne
sind ja quasi dementsprechend auch i
ihre Fußstapfen getreten was geben Sie
den für Tipps mit Reden schon aber über
die Platte auch ein bisschen ja doch
doch doch mhm
ähm da wollen sie auch nachgefragt
werden
das wäre auch eine Frage das wäentlich
die Haupt die einzige Frage gewesen die
mich richtig interessiert hätte wo ich
auch Antworten drauf hab gute und gut
gut ja von langer Hand vorbereitet wie
war die Frage elich noch mal ir was
ihren sönen mit an die Hand geben aus
ihren Erfahrungen weil die ja ich sag
mal von der Prominenz her in in ähnliche
Fußstapfen treten wie
sie ja ich muss da gar nicht so viel
erklären und reden weil die sind mE
damit aufgewachsen praktisch auch mit
meiner Einstellung zu dem ganzen und ich
glaube da haben sich sich schon das hat
sich schon ganz gut geprägt da muss man
nicht mehr viel machen ab ab zu die eine
oder andere Korrektur aber hätt sich
wirklich in Grenzen also
die machen das ganz gut die verarbeiten
das ganz gut also ihre lieblingsfrage
ist die zur Platte z.B also aber nicht
nur eine ne nee wir fangen mit einer an
und
dann wie haben sie ihren Stil gefunden
haben sie die Platte schon mal gehört
die habe ich gehört auch einer der
wenigen der so gut so gut vorbereitet
ist lieber span gib es gibt ja heute
iPods dann kann man sich das laden und
dann kann man es während der Autofahrt
hören das was man das hört ist völlig
wurscht nur dass wir wissen worüber wir
reden ja wie hat sich der Stil wie sind
sie auf den Stil gekommen wie ist der
entstanden
m den Stil gab's ja schon also ich bin
mit dem Stil mit dem Sound ja eigentlich
aufgewachsen ne was heute als draußen
wird ja heute wieder so Musik gemacht
das heißt ein Retro ne und für mich ist
ja in dem Sinne kein Retro ich habe ja
bin damit schon aufgewachsen wie gesagt
ähm ich wollte diesmal eine Platte
machen die
ähm handgemacht ist mit handgemachter
Musik
und ganz einfach und durchsichtig ja und
nicht Musik die jetzt
zugeklebt ist mit ihren Arrangements und
oder elektronischen technischen Tricks
sondern ich wollte die Songs die wir
geschrieben haben dass die auch
[Musik]
mit ganz wenigen Mittel mit den
nötigsten musikalischen
Mitteln gespielt werden ne und das ist
dann das Ergebnis und esfät mir wirklich
sehr gut plat muss man auch öfters hören
ne man entdeckt immer wieder neue Sachen
auch ich sogar ich Hörde jetzt auch
nicht jeden Tag aber wenn mal Pause ist
den komm jetzt hör du noch mal richtig
intensiv rein mit Kopfhörer und so finde
ich richtig ordentlich gemacht ja die
versprüht Spaß würde ich sagen auch das
noch ja also man hat das Gefühl die
haben alle ziemlich viel Spaß gehabt
aber ist ich bin ja jetzt kein Deutscher
Lieder der irgendwelche Botschaften hat
und SAS die Leute gibt's und die machen
auch guten Job finde ich auch alles in
Ordnung aber ich m Spaß haben nicht im
Leben vor allen auch bei der Musik ne
das soll Spaß machen beim Zuhören vor
allem wenn wir live spielen das ist der
Grund warum ich eigentlich Musik mache
live das habe ich jetzt die letzten se
Jahre in der der Pause wo keine CD
gemacht wurde sehr viel gemacht in
Deutschland sehr viel live gespielt und
das zeigt einfach dass die Leute ein
riesen Spaß dabei haben ne
sogar bei singenden schauspielern können
die Spaß haben das gibt's auch ist das
ein bisschen auch Kontrast zu ihrem
anderen Beruf wo ja eine Szene fünf Mal
wiederholt wird bis endlich im Kasten
ist ist schon natürlich ein bisschen was
anderes weil es viel direkter ist ne
also
man macht den Mund auf es kommt ein Ton
raus hoffentlich aber bis jetzt hat
immer geklappt und und schon macht man
Musik ne und schon wenn man es denn gut
und richtig
macht kommt es auch bei den Leuten an ne
und das geht dann e beim Konzert immer
hin und her und das ist auch ich denke
Musik ist auch wirklich so abgetroschen
das klingt
also diese Art Musik war auch immer ein
Aspekt von Freiheit ne also wenn wenn
jemand Musik macht und beim Konzert ist
und und und auch das zuhört dann spürt
man
immer es ist immer so ein so ein Hauch
von Freiheit mit dabei ne Musik befreit
und wenn es nur für den Moment ist äh wo
man es hört oder macht ne was ist das
für eine Freiheit die da entsteht ja das
ist einfach Gefühl ähm das aber über
alle Grenzen auch hinweggeht ja das ist
ähm soll ich was beschreiben
ist spielt die Zeit keine Rolle mehr in
dem Moment äh
seine Problemchen vergisst man äh man
gibt sich der Musik hin und ist einfach
schwerelos ja es ist einfach so man kann
die Musik genießen und äh alles wird
relativiert ja und das ist schon eine
Form der Freiheit finde ich ne und es
war ja natürlich in der hiitzeit ganz
extrem ne da war ja Musik extrem
Ausdruck von Protest Unabhängigkeit
Freiheit und Love and Peace und so und
ich glaube das hat Musik tatsächlich und
zwar alle Arten von Musik auch
Volksmusik volkstümliche Musik wen die
Leute glücklich macht warum nicht klar
sie ziehen jetzt von München nach Berlin
habe ich gelesen ja da wissen sie mehr
als ich na das glaube ich nicht was man
so alles liest meine Söhne haben
irgendwann mit Interview gesagt dass sie
gerne nach Berlin ziehen würden weil die
jetzt ein großen Film gedreht haben
ähm und so ist das entstanden und ich
habe mal gesagt ja gut kann ich mir
vorstellen aber das sind die Würfel noch
lange nicht gefallen also sie wollen in
München bleiben schauen wir mal also wir
spielen mal mit dem Gedanken da muss man
aber viel vieles durchdenken ja obwohl
ich gelesen habe dass sie ich habe es
auch nur gelesen weil vielleicht wieder
mehr als sie sie sollen richtige
Zeitungen lesen das ist wä ein
verschlafenes Nest hätten sie gesagt ja
also mün München ist ich habe da 30
Jahre gelebt ne und sehr gerne sonst wä
ich gar nicht so lange da geblieben und
es ist ein verschlafenes Nest aber das
hat ja kann ja auch ein Scham haben kann
ja auch es ist gemütlich und alles
wunderbar und alles schön nur
ich möchte auch noch mal bisschen ins
Leben springen ne also ich meine das
weiß doch jeder aber dass München so
beleidigt ist gleich das sieht man
wieder ist doch ein bisschen dörflich ne
aber das auf der anderen Seite fühle ich
mich auch immer geschmeichelt das was
man was für ein Gewicht das hat wenn man
irgendwie sowas unwichtiges eigentlich
sagt ne aber nichts gegen München es ist
eine wunderschöne Stadt also das meine
ich auch wirklich ernst ich habe mich da
sehr wohl gefühlt und tu das immer noch
aber Berlin ist nun mal so und da kann
München machen was es will es ist nun
mal eine große
äh Weltstadt geworden und entwickelt
sich immer mehr in die Richtung ja jetzt
schauen wir mal es ist noch lange nicht
irgendwie
gegessen wann kommen denn die
Umzugswagen weil ich muss ja immer
überlegen wenn ich jetzt im im Moment
München verlasse und auf Reisen bin ob
ich überhaupt wieder einreisen darf ne
ja ja na oh der schwer übel genommen
wenn Sie wahchein das geilste war die
haben sie irgendwie so so bpromis
gefragt ne Kommentar abzugeben was sie
davon halten ich kenne die gar nicht die
kennt ja kein speinen aber ist natürlich
eine gute Chance mal wieder in die
Zeitung zu kommen und mE die
Öffentlichkeit zu treten ja sollen sie
haben wann kommen denn die Umzugswagen
ich weiß es noch nicht also sie sind der
erste der er fährt okay ich glaube ihn
kein Wort ist manchmal ganz gut
so